nina wants you to make her a smoothie
[Music]
all right realization happy weekend Nina
wants you to make her a smoothie and so
uh i'm going to get my best shot she's
going to hopefully guide me and I'm
looking forward to hearing what you guys
have to take in your favorite smoothie
recipes let's do it Nina what am i doing
yeah watch the kale I can do that
otherwise the singer bro listen I'm
gonna do it my way no care what it's
like with me for you i need to do
important to have to be plain and it's
not please gonna get some it ain't
enough pocket both of your face ooh
doesn't sound good i'm going to plug in
the camera cuz funny was gonna die okay
step one let me tail let's go okay
where's the kale where's the kid hey I'm
is the fridge meeting terrace no Carrie
pizza how about some pizza yummy yummy
Susie yeah yeah
ah I found ya found some KO ok how much
kale Nina ah what all of it all over
kale is the red pepper equal to KO kayo
la keep them there cucumbers how much
one ok and yogurt banana banana the
brown banana yes these are good yes
please look at this look at this oh god
how many one banana I'm afraid to touch
these bananas to be honest have you ever
seen up an ass this black before this is
what you put in my smoothie anything
else a bit fruit frozen fruit these
qualifies fruits what is this deep
[Music]
frozen future in the freezer that's
that's been some quality guidelines meet
there thank you that's a good thing how
much is it one handful i'm going to put
my hand in this frozen fruits it's like
one giant block t were frozen fruit I
don't know how to separate that we'll
see ok guys that makes this epic
smoothie you need ready this is exactly
you need this much kale 12 promises he
need a whole cucumber
and a handful of cruises okay what do we
need to wash the cucumber with me to
wash me men cucumber you guys need to
watch banana we don't need to watch we
just need to get a tetanus shot before
and if the chaos week to watch so let's
do let's do some washing cut off the
edge of the key comfort alright we are
ready to blend what i watch the kale I
did I did the whole thing what do you
mean Creek sick I watched it oh i watch
the whole thing look at it I watched the
kale [ __ ] on houses i watched the pie
waxaa kale I'm gonna wash it
susan is garbage yeah I'll come yellow
and just and guys pro tip it was yellow
and I had sends on kale you don't blend
that stuff okay get your act together
all right now we're ready to blend we
use the Vitamix give up your Vitamix
guys are we just going to put everything
in it and just one up no no water or
water like how much water up to half
water really okay we're going with some
water in here we're not quite sure how
much maybe up to half but first we put
all of our ingredients in the vitamix
professional level here okay cut my tail
turn with the kale wash them in the
matter technic wow that's a lot of kale
we have our cucumber the professional
way to do this is to break it in half
like that and squash it into the Vitamix
with much as kin yeah okay next we have
our rough banana I feel like any special
love to hold this thing let's peel it
it's kitten on wish you just peeling it
this weekend no I can't cut it you know
cut off the top oh god oh my god this is
so the curl okay guys use your special
glove I don't need gloves because I'm
Evan Carmichael but if you're handling a
banana like this this is just nice guys
look at this this is what we keep in the
fridge this is the nice thing take
[Music]
this is good if you didn't want to touch
this I am Evan Carmichael but you
touching this we feel like it came up
but they can't even stay up by itself
it's so foggy the same source is wrong
okay guys banana don't touch the actual
banana find a way to get it in there
without touching anything to you might
get an infection okay there's six up but
that's okay what do I what do you want
to tip off honey aah okay guys maybe see
the tip like that you may think wow
that's a nasty like a test thank you
let's keep this entire dynasty banana
but oh my god so much better at home
this is nasty oh yes guys if you're
taking out like this comes to fathom
don't touch it you might die oh man ok
this is this is psychology my side of
myself is better than sent you that I'm
dissecting in the gang so far we have
this next we take this giant blocks of
frozen fruits and take a handful of this
is all so much together in one giant
block do I need to take a handful of
this
so let's see what happens this is the
system which you learn others quality
teaching channel first challenge is
undoing the not okay when there's a safe
giant not the plastic bag my tents would
be to just rip a hole in the bag I have
to deal with the very angry Chinese
women yelling at me so I need to do this
not holy cow it's frozen you know we
made special knots in China that art
extra time that you apply to frozen
bootlegs to prevent the animals from
getting in okay there we go now the wire
instructions was take a handful so let's
try that oh look at as well my hands are
frozen how is it like a handful oh
that's frozen solid anything about yes
explain to me again oh my gosh she's a
smashing yeah you're gonna win the
countertop yes you are reinvesting oh
this is a surprise video can't the end
you better be really surprised about
this amazing place enemies to you and
hurt okay any something no I'm not going
to smash it on the count em already ice
under that before hold on okay it's
really important when you're making
smoothies to not forget your hammer Jane
really important kitchen ingredients
that helps you in Model situations okay
we have our guide a pro
I want the best route oh my god guy
protest when hammering the fruits out of
the bag he mixes eyes the bag is not
going towards the floor now we need a
handful why did it it's on the fly guys
if you drop food on the floor you wash
it okay I'm gonna close this is a
handful okay handful of fruit we got we
have one and break what and great in the
one blueberry one blueberry four pieces
of pineapple and three honeydew honeydew
is this that's the perfect quantity for
this movie remember that okay when
you're buying your ingredients one
blueberry three pieces of pineapple when
you tie the bag back up make sure it's
not you and the crazy Chinese not so you
can do it last step before we plant and
that adds water because that is not
going to blend so we put some water in
here so just like that so the water goes
to see who's the waterline see there see
that water light that means it's perfect
okay look it's in it look at how gross
that Fernanda looks on top that looks
like the leaf appetizers thing I've ever
seen good luck banana bananas are
supposed to be yellow you know that all
right Vitamix
let's get our Vitamix out there it is
all right you plug that name going to
get noisy but it's going to be tasty the
perfect entrepreneur smoothie about to
come up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and we're done this is actually super
helpful because you can push it down and
come see me and we go look at that
awesome oh it's most you company what's
next okay things are falling on me will
be included let's get our starbucks
tumbler how much do you want Anita ok
doesn't matter let's get something
smaller I should get Ritter in this
electric recap we're going to be nice
too we'll give it will do this will do
the Aweber mug hey we're more month ok
pour that in there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect this is it this is the moment of
truth that we've also waiting for key
Nina Nina honey I haven't surprise for
you I have a soprano dishes look I want
to be huh okay what why don't you look
at what are you smile at the camera now
my cucumbers really trying no yes I know
what I know it's an extra flex an
imaginary p e try fer ET very exciting
you think when you see this don't if you
can clip up get-go Oh give a funny pic
this movie did you feel like its water
you still to taste it did you enjoy the
flavor that I put into this in all i see
is Roxanne and I like troubling to cover
what backwash yeah
[Music]
saw me what it is it's the ones Lutheran
with all the different guys make sure
that one blueberry pie pie yeah we're
gonna watch if they want to shoot it
make an ad for it challenge my video ok
you want it look if you did which I know
that Disney Channel this is life is
effing day or haven't cooked some ID 1
what should be later in Sweden you
cancel our look at it so annexation we
have a seat our time is worth it ya see
ya Bobby I did know these qualifiers
fruits witnesses deep and now whatever
frozen we don't want to make what is
this what size let's change this message
oh so try these days are not date no I
me and it's not mad or smooth either
symmetric so we have faced in the
freezer ok have you guys been watching I
hope you guys enjoyed this video has a
really funny videos continue easily and
whatever your long right we'll see you
soon I mean you can say that something i
did you do oh I think you do what
Chinese date burnsy